celui-ci est un coup le secteur a un
cristal Chappell c'est une chanson officielle
sabado sabado en fait de nivellement je Jamie
fatemi et son fruit tout énervé trop
maigre technologie sao paulo on y va
ouais on y va fille donc wat suan
scénario on y va yo  nous y voilà, alors
wassa matta wat dépêchez-vous,
ils travaillent sur ce
que j'aime être dans les Bellas parce que
tout est question de pouvoir et de célébrer les anciens
types de filles dans le groupe et la grosse Amy
est vous savez très confiante et aussi comme
un ami fidèle à  les autres filles et
c'est ce que j'aime vraiment dans le fait de jouer
ici ce travail d'équipe, vous savez que nous ne
traversons pas la vie seuls, nous devons compter
sur les gens et j'aime le sens du
travail d'équipe que les Barden Bellas doivent
trouver pour réussir ça alors  va y avoir
des ennemis là-bas, ils vont
nous regarder Team USA et être comme pourquoi est le
plus talentueux Australie
Je dois faire mes propres cascades aériennes dans le
film Je me suis entraîné pendant cinq semaines pour faire la
42e routine de cascades qu'ils montrent  moi du
sperme doc  omo vector cal vous dérange monsieur
des ouais et j'ai peur des hauteurs mais
Elizabeth elle est excellente à
Heights et avant que je ne le fasse, elle est allée là-
bas sans formation et pouvait simplement le
faire Adventure Travel vous a laissé inspirer
tout le monde à faire je veux dire
oh non  elle n'a pas de sous-vêtements nous avons une
situation de commando elle tourne ce
navire un jeune gentleman veut manger qui
a été créé avec impatience c'est un cool pour
le bâton bonjour Exeter gras moi un peu de
chance dan moon yo sauce soja gingembre nous sommes
cool de voir ainsi  les femmes, s'il vous plaît, donnez l'exemple, en
particulier, vous avez senti que ces filles
avaient brisé toutes les barrières sur
leur chemin,
c'est ma fille